welcome everybody if you are here for
the sentiment analysis toriel you're in
the right place
my name is Fatma tariiji I am a data
science fellow at coincide and my
colleague is the backbone let's put it
that way so the more or less the
principle here is hoping this sorry I
realize when I say this out loud so the
the sort of the bright pink ones I guess
these are for emergencies so if that's
if you're having if you need help you
know put this up on your laptop
somewhere I can see you and I'll come
over and occasionally will ask a
question just to make sure everything is
ok so right now for instance we're going
to ask you to download the zip file at
this URL so once you've got it download
it and if you can start off we do put a
number make sure that you can load up
the introduction one and then we will
green sticky something we can see it
then that means I will know that
everything is good and that will help
ourselves actually just the quick show
of hands as there's anybody here never
used a Jupiter note along those lines
same lines using as anyone you have
prior experience using one you never use
scikit-learn
just just go okay that's cool as well
yes definitely deca so okay so we will
spend the first five ten minutes for you
to just set up for your environment and
like though it said if you have any
questions during that time please let us
know if you are having any issues with
the tinyurl there's also a git repo if
it is easier for you and if you are more
familiar with get you can also download
the repo from this URL that as an
introduction notebook so yeah so once
you get to the state where you've got
this notebook load it up if you just put
up your green so you know this is the
introduction IP my nd so just so that I
know that then what we've got we've sort
of got there then we also make sure
thank you
thank you
like
yes it's like you're good to go for the
stage that we are at for example right
now we're downloading stuff and you've
never finished downloading you'll put it
up so that and if anybody's behind so
that we can you know get to them and
help them so everyone is on the same
page so it helps one we're like you know
going on it step by step way so that you
know
alright seems like okay so I will give a
couple of more minutes than available so
if you have installed your repository
you might want to start and running this
first cell while we are importing the
libraries because especially the library
natural language toolkit and ltk will
take a couple of minutes to download so
if we can just go ahead and run this
self to see if you're encountering any
issues please do so you can also install
and I'll take it in the shop you can use
Conda or the
install please let us know Amy and while
we are doing that I think I'll go ahead
and start talking a little bit about
what sentiment analysis is before we got
it how many of you have been familiar or
played with it a little bit or know a
little bit about and our P natural
language processing or sentiment
analysis okay very good so we did not
actually expect a lot of prior knowledge
so we kept it pretty simple so we are
hoping it's going to be easy
hopefully it's not going to be too easy
but we will be introducing some of the
concepts and and vocabulary in sentiment
analysis so to start with what is
sentiment analysis sentiment analysis is
the process of understanding you know
premia nor a sentence and they give a
piece of text and an also spoken
language because speech to text
applications are also very common it is
one of the subfields of natural language
processing and as you can see in this
diagram we have different tasks when we
are doing natural language processing
such as machine learning question
answering machine translation
question answering sentiment analysis
language model among others today what
we are going to focus in sentiment
analysis most of the time when you are
working with natural language processing
you will have different models for each
of these different tasks but current
research is actually trying to come up
with models and architectures that can
answer and solve the problems for all
these tax tasks at once with with the
idea of multitasking so when we are
doing sentiment analysis we usually are
trying to do four things first we are
trying to identify an opinion in a given
text to see if it is if it is if we can
classify it in a given class such as
positive negative or neutral and you can
also have other classes that you can
customize and create for your own model
which will be a multi multi
classification model what we are then
doing is we are trying to extract some
features which is a common practice in
other machine machine learning models
and applications as well which means we
are identifying the aspects being
commented on in the in the text such as
the price of a product color of a
product and n different features that
our product if you are doing your
product review and trying to get some
sentiment form from that like they will
be doing today actually then we go ahead
and classify our sentiment whether the
opinion is in somewhere in between the
polarity like positive negative and as I
can as I said you can also make it more
sophisticated by saying very positive
very negative and and anything in
between and feel free to stop me if you
have any questions as I go over it is
because I'm gonna not gonna spend too
much time in the in the conceptual part
of it and so that we can get to
application and spend our time in the
most useful way so how does it bring
insight to text textual data assuming
that most of you have been doing some
work with data science that's why we are
here at PI data what do we do with
something or what can we do with
sentiment analysis where you
you know in in our data science work so
honestly it has a lot of practical
applications and it's gaining a lot of
popularity among the data science
community and what we can do with that
these are just some of the main examples
that you will encounter in other places
when people talk about sentiment
analysis we can look at product reviews
market analysis and customer feedback
which is you all know text is being
generated online constantly and it's
very time consuming and requires a lot
of effort to understand and make sense
of the often of the text and sentiment
analysis is actually providing us a very
useful and powerful if done correctly
tool to get sense of it very quickly
it allows us to make sense of data in
ways that enhance the techniques that we
are already using in our data science
practices sentiment analysis is also a
classification problem where the
classifier tells us if the sentiment is
one of the classes that we have been
using but we can also we are not going
to go into that part but sentiment
analysis can also be done using deep
learning and using deep nor narrow
networks where we are not necessarily
ding supervised learning what do we what
do we do with this insight that we are
gaining through sentiment analysis from
data we can automate things we can
improve our reaction time or response
time to our customers and clients and we
can enhance our businesses in different
ways that I you know I haven't even put
up in here overall what we are doing
with sentiment analysis we are
transforming some form of unstructured
data into a structured form so that we
can get some sense of it pretty quickly
and then proceed with our other next
stage in this picture you see three
different classes that are I will say
very classic and the main classes that
are being used in sentiment analysis
work and models but you can change them
you can make it more powerful and if
it's sophisticated if you want it to
I think you already covered why is it
valuable it requires it brings us a lot
of it saves us a lot of time and it
gives us the ability to get sense
and insight to data that that is
valuable to us into our businesses any
questions so far all right so I'm gonna
go over some basic terminology I know
some of you are familiar but for those
of you who have never been introduced to
these concepts some of the words and
concepts that you will be hearing when
you are working with NLP or more
specifically at sentiment analysis will
be Star Wars tokenization lamentations
stemming world embedding them text
classification
I put brief descriptions of each but
some of someone we are not going to use
all of them today but we will be looking
at some stuck words what they are and
how do we use them and why do we need
them why did we classify them like that
Star Wars are actually the words that we
use in our language such as articles
like the is and and and as such that do
not really add any value to our language
and to the text that we are using you
might have hundreds of the in a piece of
text but if you do not if you keep them
in your text while we are processing and
training your model you might get some
results saying no this is a very
important word because it has been
repeated so many times
the idea behind listing out stop words
is that we do not want to we didn't want
not want to get some false positives
about the importance of words that are
being repeated and as we will see Co
going forward the NLT K library uses a
very easy way to just pull them out of
our data and clean it a little bit more
for training tokenization is basically
it's putting our text into the little
segments so that we can use them as
features and then extract them from our
text moving forward we're not going to
use some limitation but I put an example
in there if we are seeing a word that is
in the past tense the limit position
will allow us to bring it to its present
tense so that we know what
actually it's or our model knows how to
how to learn it setting is an important
one stemming reduces a word into a stem
or root from from the word did I put it
wrong in here okay so if that word has
some X's and suffixes then stemming will
bring it to its basic root form you will
see in one of the examples that the
stammers that are given to us from the
libraries such as an LT K are not
perfect but they are so most of the time
in many of the models are useful to get
and increase our accuracy of the model
that we will be we will be using or
creating all of these things are
actually in the stage of pre-processing
our data textual data and we will be
doing some of these in the in the next
exercise and the warm-up and you will
get a better sense of it I'm gonna skip
the the engrams and all in Werdum
boredom Eddings is actually an important
one because our machines are not are not
able to read the words when we give it a
text it doesn't like like us it doesn't
understand what the world is we need to
put it in a form we need to convert it
in a form that it can understand and the
way we do that we put it in the world
vectors what does it mean the word is
being presented as a set of as a vector
of numbers and words that are similar
will have similar vectors in the same
vector space so going forward with the
open source and LP libraries if you have
no prior experience with doing natural
language processing work and practice
there are a lot of open source libraries
out there that will way that will allow
you to do a lot and also free data sets
labeled data sets that you can use that
there's a lot that can be done without
having having to pay for anything
basically well we will be using mainly
today is NLT K and some of the NLP
specific open source libraries are
listed in here and there are actually
many others for designed for some
some nuance and different purposes going
back to the word word embedding another
way of and another where we're talking
about this idea is text representation
what we are going to do we are going to
use a method from the NLT Kay to do this
but before we get to that I want to
explain what bag of words is for those
of you who have never heard of it bag of
words is actually a common method for
extracting features from text what it
does it actually takes and counts the
presence of a word in a given piece of
text and then puts it in directors and
that becomes our features that we can
use later on when you're training and
one problem with bag of words though it
does not really count for the position
of the word in a sentence and it may
this may become a problem if you're
actually developing the model yourself
but since we are actually using a pre
implemented model today this is not
gonna be an issue for us but going
forward if you want to learn more about
it and want to create better models more
sophisticated models bag of course is
probably not the method that you will
want to use there are a few most more
improved I will say not necessarily more
sophisticated but improved methods such
as tf-idf and it gives us a better sense
because it puts weights in the in the
words and sometimes accounts for the
position and and the repetition of the
of the word and a given text any
questions so far I hope it wasn't too
fast or too boring alright so what we
are going to do today hopefully this
gave you some idea about why using
sentiment analysis or any other NLP work
in data science kind of work or or in in
our professional businesses is important
hopefully we got the idea a little bit
and then we will we will proceed from
there what we are going to do we will
build a little sentiment analysis
classifier in Python using some of the
libraries such as an L TK and
scikit-learn if
do not have any experience with cyclin
that's perfectly fine we will I try to
be as exploratory as I called in the
exercises but police asked us if you
have any any issues about that but if
you have any questions about that
go ahead so the the general strategy
we're going to use there's so beyond
this introduction note there's three
other notebooks that we'll look at the
first one is called pre-processing text
with an LT K so that will illustrate
some of the ideas partners just
explained about bag of words and what
you know vector Isis and a lot of these
weird kind of notions of changing a
string of text with words in it into a
vector and the reason for doing that is
that most of the machinery and all the
tools in sight in machine learning and
expect to have matrices and vectors
these mathematical structures for
manipulations for doing numerical
calculations so you somehow have to take
something like a review from Amazon or
an article from Wikipedia or something
of that nature and turn it into a vector
that has numbers in certain positions so
that all of our learning machinery the
tools the libraries can do numerical
computation so tf-idf yeah and any many
others actually so don't worry yeah so
the idea of today is basically to just
get off you know dip our toes in to
learn a little bit of vocabulary the key
thing is you know people like taught
maths paper has been
many months years sort of working with a
lot of these tools and they're learning
it as they learn these things and
they're very familiar with it
what what we want to do is just sort of
develop enough vocabulary and then and
see through through first of all this
first notebook here and then the to
exercise one and exercise to exercise
one is working with the toy data set
exercise two is working with some
reviews of Alex and just sort of to
process those to see whether or not
they're positive or negative just to
sort of simple workflows we we probably
will get to the end of those by it today
but if we if not I'm thinking or if we
get through maybe one of the exercises
it's enough like the second one they
could be able to work through it
yourself but again the key idea is just
to get enough of an understanding of the
core vocabulary the core ideas and a
little bit of working code so that you
can then go and explore on your own
it's never easy sort of you know picking
up all of these tools when you learn
machine learning when you do natural
language processing there's all of these
you know all of these weird acronyms and
toolkits and libraries out there the
core ideas are you know sort of some of
the things Batman has already outlined
for us and I just want to baby I just
wanted we emphasize that you know if
I'll call today's not to try and do it
you know it's a family or there's lots
and lots of active research in this in
this area at the moment we're just
trying to sort of get enough foundation
that the ideas make sense so that when
you actually look at the documentation
for NLT Day and other libraries like oh
I know what that word means I know you
know I know
thank you yeah perfect thank you thank
you so much for clarifying that all
right we thought I think we're gonna
move to our second notebook which is
called a Swan processing text with an
ltk you can go ahead and open it and
this is actually a little warm-up some
of the code has already been placed in
here for you and if there is some that
hasn't been there already such as
importing all the libraries you're just
gonna copy and paste it from the
introductory file and put it in this and
there's no exactly yes
so you see that the first import from an
LT K stem module is porter stemmer it's
one of the older stammers that an al TK
provides for us what it does it just put
as I mentioned what stemming was it
brings the worst to its roots form and
then it allows us to to get a little bit
increase accuracy in models not always
but most of the time because it also
depends on the data type of data that
you have so we are going to import
porter stemmer if there's another one
snowball stemmer which is arguably is
it's relatively better but you can also
play with that later if you want for
this exercise I picked porter stemmer
this is one of the as I said older and
more known once I should say and now we
will import this function called word
tokenize which will allow us to tokenize
our words so that we can put it into
vectors and then process it for our
model to when we are training
our messages so what you can do in here
you can just get the imports from the
first introductory actually we won't
really need a SK learning here but I'll
just put it in here just in case it
gives us an error I'll just move down
this notebook and then you can ask me if
you have any questions so in the second
cell of code you will see that I put as
my dataset it sounds funny a couple of
sentences and then I put that sent those
sentences into a data frame so that I
can get a better picture of it later on
in exercise one you will have a better
chance to use some of the other
libraries like pandas which I'm assuming
meaning of you might be familiar with to
get and more to get a better inside of
the data and what it looks like so as
you can see this one has only one
sentence and and one roll it's really
nothing sophisticated but this is what
we will be doing going forward just
putting our data set into a data frame
so that we can put it into different
forms that we would like to work with
this will require some pandas if you're
not familiar with it please let us know
so there are different ways to inspect
the data that we have given all the open
source great tools that we have and if
you want to look at what stemming looks
like I have put in an example sentence
in this cell and then I'm I want to know
how I can actually how the stemming off
this thing works by creating an instance
of porter stemmer so that i can use it
and then putting it in a putting it in a
for loop where I can stand each word in
the in the sentence that I put up there
if you run this stuff you're gonna get
an error oh that's weird
I have oh I might have him weightless
okay so what you're gonna do you're
gonna yes it's not so guys I'm sorry
okay so we are gonna tokenizer the I
know right yes we tokenize the words
first so that we can look each word in
the sentence first by looking at each
word and now you will see this
weird-lookin sentences that is
supposedly the instant you will see that
not all of them are actually sending the
dictionary meaning or morphological
meaning that we will that will make
sense to us but it's not the porter
stemmer or any other stemmer for that
reason is actually not perfect but it's
still useful most of the time as I
mentioned you will be getting a better
accuracy if you sum your words as you
can see this one makes sense sub-fields
was reduced down to Southfield just
removing the removing the plural suffix
that is yes I think what happened there
is that porter stemmer thought it was a
plural suffix with the s and just remove
that so you will encounter this kind of
issues a lot with this kind of stammers
as I mentioned they are definitely not
perfect yes right right remember it's a
rule-based stammer when they all garden
behind porter stemmer is very rule-based
and anything that falls outside it
sometimes creates these kind of issues
and most of the time this is trivial
when we are training the data yeah you
will see this kind of like you know
words that actually morphological it
don't even make sense to us and same
thing happened with the language as well
I'm not sure what rule was applied to
the suffix eat the letter e but it was
also cut off as you can see in the
processing it did a good job and it just
gave us the process knowing that ing is
a suffix and it needs to remove that
bring it to the root so if we go ahead
and demonstrate what tokenizing looks
like we have a sentence which is a
grammatically correct doesn't have to be
to tokenize it do you have a question ok
and we have a sentence I mean we'll
tokenize it by using this word took a
nice function from an LT K we could like
in Plaistow you could literally do that
with a split or or anything like that
but doing this with wor tokenizing is
more useful in different scenarios where
it's simple it may not work if you want
to play with it you can go ahead in the
next self and write your own sentence
tokenize it and then stem it I'll give
you like a minute a couple of minutes to
do so if you would like to and then I'll
keep going for the next examples and why
they are there all these steps hopefully
will be useful when rendering the
exercise one you can go ahead and I'm
not go ahead but you can go back to this
notebook and and look at some of the
things that we have done here to
complete the exercises in exercise one
file
[Music]
so we have covered stemming and
tokenizing so far which is useful some
of the two main two main things that we
will be doing one we are pre-processing
our data to get it ready for training
all right I'll go ahead and run on this
next cell where we are before before I
do that let me explain what whitespace
tokenizer is an ltk library gives us
different options how to tokenize are
sent our text one of them is whitespace
tokenizer if you have a data set which
it looks very weird and it has like a
bunch of white spaces in it and we're
tokens will probably not work I mean it
will work but if prologue will still
keep the white spaces in there so if you
have if you have such a case you might
want to go ahead and try whitespace
tokenizer to get rid of that and
whitespace tokenizer is also going to
get rid of things like like n lines and
tabs and any other commands that you
might have like engrained inside your
data that you have if you were to try to
do it manually or using other other
methods from from Python might be a
little bit tedious and because you want
to save time and you want to speed
things up whitespace organizer might be
a good option for you depending on what
kind of data you have so if I run this
cell you will see that all the things
that are that were in my sentence like n
lines and tabs will be gone so in the
first print you will see that they are
not there but you know they're on
different lines still so it's still
reading the end the end line but then
when we go back to when we go down to
tokenizer like what whitespace tokenizer
you will see that you get actually a
beautiful yet organized list of words
which you can then embed
yes mm-hmm
definitely if you want to play with it
you can go ahead and do so in here but
I'll keep going with the regular
expression tokenizer some of you may not
know what reg X is reg X is actually
trying to find it yeah
there's that you can afford to slow down
alright okay you never know good 11:45
okay okay we can slow down all right
yeah it was like for you probably
exercises will take more time so how is
it going so far it doesn't make sense
is it too easy is it like okay I'm
getting it or it's like I don't know
what's going on yeah a number of times
I've gone and done training and it's
just you know getting things to actually
install and the have the libraries
people's machines has been so painful
yeah I uh yeah I was worried about an
ulti k2 because sometimes takes a lot
about this with anaconda a few minutes
ago right it is not that long ago that
just having things working on your
machine was incredibly painful and so
it's it's amazing to me that just in the
span of a few years it has become like
alone download anaconda everything works
they probably have anaconda on their
machines like
did anyone try the whitespace tokenizer
exercise there little one I think so but
if you can see here like when you print
the first I'm assuming this first
printout is from this one just lying so
you still have the spaces right you
haven't done anything with them but when
you come to the after the tokenizer you
don't have them it looks like this for
you right line there in the vector but
when we are putting the vectors into
into and I'm sorry putting these listen
to the word vectors where it is
represented as a number it will count
those white spaces as if it's something
that will poop like it I don't know a
number in there to represent it because
it will count it like you know because
white spaces counters as a character in
encoding but actually it's doing what it
is supposed to be doing right now and
it's getting rid of the white space even
if you don't you're not like seeing it
as such because we already have already
went that process and tokenizer voice
already has taken care of it on the
bottom it's like separate yeah yeah
mm-hmm does it make sense okay sure
yes because yeah we're talking as just a
function
a method that another care providers but
y-space tokido is actually a class so it
comes with some other methods insider
that takes care of all those white
spaces and tabs and analyze and all that
that's why we need to create an instance
of it it's but we're talking as is
basically just a function
it's from the tokenized class but the
way we imported it in the enve
if you move up in the import saw you
will see that the way we import it from
the tokenized class is just just that
and it's not it's not a class but as you
can as you can see like like we always
do in python we capitalize our classes
right that will be give me a key about
like oh is a class or is it just a
method that i gave you it giving me so
that means like if it is a class i
probably has like anyway i actually know
but it has like so many other bunch of
methods that helps whitespace tokenizer
to do what it is supposed to do because
whitespace tokenizer
not only takes care of the space but it
takes care of some other like you know n
lines and then tabs and this and that
all that stuff so i'm assuming for each
of those it will have a different method
inside the class that's why you need
that class rather than just a simple
function
Wow I actually forgot it a peat in here
well it depends on the yeah different
yeah that and also it depends on the
data set you are working with if it has
a lot of issues like you know things
that it can take care of it will really
be helpful if you just skim your day
data set like working in a different
setting then you all see will see do I
really need this one or the other one or
you can try both and then see which one
has a better output but there are there
are places and and scenarios that
y-space tokenizer is actually more
helpful than the regular work tokenizer
or or drag x1 but yeah
yeah
all right I'm going to give you a couple
more minutes and then we'll keep going
so that we can start with the next
exercise
I think in practice it has been done and
used to see if it will be helpful at all
but I don't think I have used it by
myself I mean I don't um in Alta Cain's
are relatively older libraries that was
it's still very widely used but it's one
of the first ones that has been out
there and it's mostly used when we are
doing sentiment analysis or diffident
out NLP tacks in the eye no no and all
the NLP tests you can you can get make
use open ltk but what I was going to say
if you are doing some natural language
processing work in in the traditional
machine learning sense as opposed to
deep learning you will be using these
libraries so what I have been lately
doing mostly deep learning part of the
stuff where I am using like you know
pre-trained language models and chance
for learning and all that so I don't
really need this kind of like a little
work that I need to I mean I still need
to prep process my texts and all that
but you know an ltk is very big in our
family for people who are just getting
into an LP so that's why we chose to use
it today but yeah going back to your
question I know that it has been done
but I have not practice to practice it
myself
all right okay I'm gonna go ahead and
and very good if we talk about Rex
tokenizer for those of you who are not
familiar with regular expressions it's a
way to find a certain pattern and search
in strings and pieces of texts that we
have and it can take different
parameters depending on what you're
searching and what we are trying to
exclude in your search and here in this
cell what I am trying to do by using
this dash and W plus I'm telling my
tokenizer that I'm only interested in
things that are words that are qualified
that qualify as words and give me only
those in this text that I am giving to
you and I'm this tokenizer a sentence
which has dashes and exclamation marks
and all that and what it is going to do
hopefully it will just get rid of all
that and then give me a list of
tokenized words that are free from all
the punctuation and things that are not
defined as words does it make sense and
regex organizer can take different
arguments depending on what you want to
do and I will encourage you to go and
explore what else it can do it's it's
actually very well it can be very
powerful depending on the data set the
type of set that you have and if you
want to play with it you can go ahead
and play with it and but I will move
down to stop words as I mentioned in the
beginning of my in the beginning of our
tutorial sub words are the words that do
not necessarily add meaning to the text
and but can negatively impact the
accuracy and output of our models later
on so what we usually want to do we want
to remove them from our data data set in
our processing step so that we don't
have to worry about them so if you want
to look at what English language stop
words are defined in NL teacake we will
need to run this cell and we will see a
bunch of what Edwards and
prepositions and things like that and
contractions and things like that that
does not necessarily change or have
meaning in the word itself you know I
want to get rid of this output because
it's actually very long but if you look
at it it's quite long and has all the
things that will not necessarily be
important when we are trying to make
sense of or get sentiment from a piece
of text you can you can I believe you
can good question I need to double check
but I believe it allows you if not an LT
K there are ways that you can customize
it and like you know these are my stop
wars you can even like create it
yourself and say that these are just
stop words that I don't want to look at
and I just want to remove them from my
vocabulary for my text for my class sure
yeah but yes a great question that
actually will go back to engrams which I
did not quite explain because we're not
going to use it
Ingram's is a way where when we are
evaluating our text we are evaluating it
in like and it's standing for the number
of words that we want to evaluate at
once
for example if n is 2 it will be a
bigram where we are very very valuating
wasn't happy together and as opposed to
happy so that will give us a better more
accurate representation but when it
comes to vectorizing words it doesn't
really as I mentioned bag of words does
not really care about the order of the
words so it wouldn't matter if there's
it wasn't behind happy for this method
that we will be we will be using but in
other settings it will it will make a
difference and overall what our goal is
to represent each word as a vector so
wasn't and happy would have different
vectors so it still will not affect what
we are trying to do with with this type
of work does that make sense okay but
that's a great point yeah and there are
ways to overcome that like engrams and
and different methods as well
I'm sorry which one uh-huh which one
what was the word yeah yes yeah yes yeah
that's a good question yeah I know a
great question as I mentioned and ltk is
one of the relatively older libraries so
newer what newer libraries and tools are
actually trying to account for that like
especially Twitter data and all kind of
social media where slang is very common
and there are words that are not in the
dictionary so they are trying to find
different ways to account for those I
think in ltk was trying to do that by
using some of the Colo kills that are
well-known or relatively well known but
it's not quite there so if you were to
try just this with a very simple bag of
words model on eye on a Facebook or
Twitter a text that has a lot of slang
in it that I was not grammatically
correct or anything like that you
probably will not have a very high
accuracy of your training I don't know
quite in detail but I know that some of
the other libraries are trying to add
them in if they are common enough like
lol and things like that but there are
different ways sometimes stemming them
in a certain way or lemon station in LA
they try they try different options but
I think the biggest or the most useful
thing right lies people turn to like
more deep learning kind of fluent
language language models and transfer
learning where you don't have to worry
about any of those because it's already
learning that yeah I mean if you if you
want to go further and learn more about
like an LP methods and things I will
encourage you to look at like
transformers and self attention
mechanisms and all that they are
actually getting pretty good of taking
care of that kind of problems that
previous models and libraries are not
very good at so yeah but that is that is
that has been a common problem and NLP
researchers and practitioners or like I
mean what do we do with this we need to
find a way to to figure out and
understand text when it is not
grammatically correct or morphologically
meaningful actually that is a great
question there that I know that there is
it has been an open research I think it
still is
for a while they are actually doing work
figuring out how to interpret emojis
because they they carry a lot of meaning
and even it contributes to reasoning and
when we are trying to understand and
reason about the text so there is work
that is going on about emojis and it
because it basically became like part of
our language now when I will be text or
when I were to eat we use some sort of
emojis so they are taking it into
account right now it's I believe it's
still like you know open and people are
trying different things to overcome that
but yeah
yeah
but it's only on slack if you use
different tools so you probably will
don't have you will have like weird
symbols that doesn't make sense and it's
like to a regex thing I'll just wipe it
off you know some people use that use
drag Express and I don't want to I don't
want the emojis and you know I just get
them but yeah we are done with the
pre-processing warm-up so we can go to
exercise one if everyone is okay with it
yeah so we've done we've done the Reg
expects I mean I I hope I explained it
well by any questions about the reg ex
tokenizer
please let me know yeah regular
expressions are a computer science thing
yeah there's a very useful for data
scientists to know for a lot of text
processing applications and for actually
for a lot of systems kind of operations
when you're trying to find regular paths
yes you know in strings of text and in a
regular repeatable way often for things
like matching filename patterns like a
file under school that's so any 22
operations on them so it's well sort of
well-known in computer science
literature but it turns out of course
it's very useful also in this particular
context as well and so it is in itself
the topic of its own
books but it is something that can be
done in the context of natural language
processing which is why yeah I think
you're probably right we can move on to
the to exercise yeah and then we'll take
a look at try and do one sort of work
through with a toy dataset yeah so
there's pretty much no starter code in
this one I left it up to you looking at
the purposing notebook that we have just
covered you can actually use the same
code in this one as well and why don't
you go ahead and start you know
importing the libraries and then using
the data frame and all that you can
refer back to the previous notebook as I
said and also let us know if you have
any questions what we are going to do in
this exercise basically we are going to
apply all the tools and methods that we
have learned and covered in to a very
tiny toy data set of length of 27 lines
basically it's yeah it's very small
so you will see in this for loop that I
provided part of it for you is I am
assuming that the data set is already
put into a data frame which you will be
doing in the first cell and then I'm
only interested in the column which is
called verified reviews and you can if
you want to and if you are familiar with
handles you can also do some inspection
in the in the data set as well or you
can just open the file and see how it
looks like what columns are there but
just to make it clear verified reuses is
the column where it has the text after
text the review of the products that the
data set has and that's what we're
interested in and that's what we will be
cleaning up and processing it yeah so
this is a TSP file yeah so you will see
that we have a few columns in here and
this is the one we will be working on
where we have the text and variation is
the name of the product that the review
was on as he as you can see this data
set does not really differentiate
between different products but it has a
rating for each and it has the features
like the color of it what it is called
and all that in a different column and
then we have the reviews if I can open
this up I have included I believe some
inspect modeling distortions for the
second exercise or maybe even in this
one where you can where you can see how
we can actually go into this data set
without having to open the file and
looking into it using some pandas
methods
it's not very important for our purposes
today for the sentiment analysis but
using pandas you can actually get a a
better understanding of the data you can
divide it into dates and then set a
sentiment analysis on that within those
dates to see if there's anything has
changed as opposed to last year or this
year you can divide your data set into
different different parts if you wanted
to so there's really a lot to do
yeah of course the not 27 lines like
tooth or even the full data set that we
are using today is actually very small
it has only over I believe 20 100 or so
reviews it's it's relatively small as
opposed to so many other review data
sets that we have but we did not want to
have like issues downloading and running
into problems so I kept it very small
but going forward you can use this model
on different data sets which might be
bigger you just need to tweak a little
bit
the solutions are dire if your
absolutely stuck you can't look at it
but I encourage you not to if you don't
want to understand what's going on in
here but we provided the solutions to
you as well that you can inspect later
if things are not clear
you will see that in some of the cells
there are two deuce for you and some of
them are already provided you just need
to look at it and see if it makes sense
but if you have any questions please let
us know this is the part where we are
starting to use scikit-learn
which is a very widely used machine
learning library I will say in data
science also and so we will be using
some of the methods that it provides for
us
[Music]
tab
it should it might be delimiter into
instead of SAP maybe maybe you should
[Music]
how's it going Oh
can you check what your prison working
directory is by maybe just create a new
sellable and yeah just say PW deep ok
all right so you are in the exercises
hello it doesn't this
I think this pack doesn't really get to
that this pack that I provided what you
might want to do you can CD back one CD
dot dot in this in this one ok CD doctor
and now you can do yet there you go now
I should see this path now try it
oh that looks correct the data is in the
data folder yeah
[Music]
can you actually assigned that data
frame to the data set oh yeah that might
be - yeah so try to try that yeah and
two ducks yeah okay now try my work can
you let me see how it is
is it how did you make North Shore oh
yeah you didn't meet me do you assign
this line entire line to your data set
yeah like like hideth actually you need
to reassign your a sign it right so go
to this second line where it says PDS
and go to the beginning of it and do
data set EKOS let's see if that's gonna
work yeah so why don't you get the
second yeah because you know you need
you might need that yes do the same in
the previous one as well
okay now try it okay yes it's alright oh
okay put the dots to ensure that's in
there just one and the same at all okay
now you can't looking - yeah still still
not finding okay it's very weird the
pass should work can you check your
present working directory if you're
having a path problem for finding the
toy data set try check for your present
working directory and see where you are
you might want to go back and go back
one step
once one folder up and being that main
directory
this is a
the reason I'm doing this and out early
that's how we don't need that I just
want me in that right because that's
where this
now
[Music]
[Music]
so if you're done with this step we can
keep going to the next one
and let us know I hear any questions if
we don't finish exercise - by the end of
the tutorial you will see that a lot of
the steps are the same or very similar
and you can actually complete it I'm if
you get the exercise while I'm working
you will you will not have any issues
completing the second one hopefully it
has only a couple more steps why we are
actually evaluating the model of course
yeah so I was a shoe okay okay
Pat's
sure
when you say like hop like each word in
a sentence is that what you mean yeah
in this exercise that we are doing here
we do not do much of that especially as
I mentioned with bag of words it's a
very simplistic way of vectorizing and
in feature extraction it's just telling
us this word occurs this many times in
this text so it doesn't really tell us
much it doesn't even care about the
position of the word that it takes place
in the sentence but there are other ways
where we actually it's still useful it's
not like completely useless but it still
can tell us if a sentiment in a sentence
is is positive or negative and actually
I think I provided in an example in the
second exercise where you will see that
it's actually picking up that you know
if when I when somebody says I love my
Alexa it's actually a very positive
thing it doesn't care where the love is
or if there is no it's able to see that
there's no like don't I don't love this
in front of it or there is no negation
in the sentence that actually accounts
for it but we do not necessarily in this
example we do not necessarily look into
the meaning and the value of it the
other method which we mentioned tf-idf
is a is is doing a better job doing that
it gives more weight to the words and
and vocabulary that it thinks more
important and meaningful and valuable
for the entire text and the entire
corpus that we have but there are as I
mentioned we wanted to keep this
exercise beginner-friendly so we do not
really want to in
investigate that as much but there are
definitely certain ways that we can get
a better sense of what word is
meaningful or more valuable to this
sentence which one adds more meaning to
the overall meaning or off of the scent
and all that but great question so one
point so where is this so I think if you
scroll up a cell's corners so we look at
these instructions I just had a question
there that was a good question
so if we start off we're using a list to
represent an empty list to start off to
represent the corpus in the first line
yes so the question that was posed was
if you have the same word or repeated in
text that means your corpus will have
repetitions yes yes and we want that we
want that we want that because bag of
words later on my mere when we go to the
next cell is gonna tell us this word has
been repeated five or ten times as
opposed to one or two so that means it
accounts for it and it means this is
this is going to be one of my max
features when we are doing the feature
extraction it's gonna tell us that is
one of the words that has been repeated
more times than the other one so it
might be relative rates of repetition
yes wait yes we do definitely know it
might be a little bit like not so clear
and there are a lot of assumptions and
these functions that we are just calling
as most as black box but there's enough
reasoning behind it when they were
designing these algorithms to create
these methods so
and during the reason if it is not clear
already the reason that we have this
corpus as opposed to that we had the
data set we just want to have a cleaned
set after this trip processing step yeah
we are a little bit of time show the
solution and then you might want to go
over the evaluation step and White has
important and all that yeah okay all
right so
how's everyone doing
I know I know we thought yeah yeah yeah
but you will see that even if we don't
have time which probably won't for the
second exercise it's very similar it
just goes a couple more steps further to
actually evaluate the model to see what
how accurate it is and it's I try to
made it as self-contained
as possible so you can actually go home
and do it and then run it and then
compare with the solution if you wanted
to hopefully yeah
yeah
yes we will in the next couple minutes
yeah but we definitely won't get to the
second exercise some of some people are
still in this stage but I think they
might want to go ahead and talk about
vectorizing and then fit transform and
more like scikit-learn
type of work so all right so as I
mentioned earlier about the bag of words
model and word endings and how we put
words in a way that the models and the
computer can understand as vectors of
numbers this is what we are going to do
that in this cell where we are importing
count vectorizer form scikit-learn
library and what conflict arises is
gonna do is actually basically it's
going to take our tokenize and pair
processed and cleaned up data and it
will vectorizer each word is going to
have their own vector in the same vector
space and the words that are similar
will have similar vectors so if I run
this it's not going to work because they
complete the previous stage is not
completed but do you want to talk about
the fit and transform method once I
could learn a little bit that has a very
standard interface that has been made so
that encourages experimentation with
different kind of algorithms so there's
two sort of dominant clauses in there
that are that are used to make sort of
Python objects one is called estimators
another one is called transformers so
the Transformers have so it seems a
little bit strange for this particular
way of doing things
so what you'll often do is your your
limp or a transformer class white can
vectorize it you'll instantiate it with
maybe a few keyword arguments so here
word is that were creating an object of
count vectorizer from the class count
vectorizer with Max reaches 100 and
we're assigning that to the identifier
we're binding that the identifier
vectorizer so once that object is
instantiated the max features argument
is actually it's a number that you can
not necessarily arbitrarily about
depending on the size of your data set
you want to pick that many number of
words that are most repeated in there in
your data set you will see that in the
second example that number will be I
believe I put like 1000 500 or 1000 or
something like that because it's a very
small data set I kept that number very
small you kind of decide how many words
you want to pick as the most common and
that will store that those words in the
in the in the vector and it will just
say okay these are the most repeated
ones they should have more importance to
the overall sentiment that you are
trying to or those are going to be your
features basically there's like each
word is gonna be like extracted as a
feature for your model to work
it depends you you like when you are I
guess like tuning and changing your
parameters you might want to play with
different numbers to see if it does
anything in your accuracy when you
actually run the around the model and
but there's really not like a one magic
number that you will put you kind of
like find like a good ratio between the
size of your data set and what how many
words do you think are mostly appear it
yeah so one thing it reflects is the
size of your vocabulary yeah so if
you've got a bunch of reviews and you're
thinking you you use count have you use
max words is 100 then that means the
most 100 most common words are going to
be expected for the reviews and
everything else is going to move on away
if you use 10,000 which is you know
probably a more reasonable number that
reflects you know in English potential
which language that people control words
wrong and what will happen is those will
get transformed into a vectors in which
each position in the vectors are going
to be 0 or some positive value depending
on the number of counts of how that is
how many times that words occurred in
the review and each position in the
vector corresponds to a different word
right so the first column might
correspond to the word but it won't be
though cuz that would be able to
movement stop words but it might be held
across and the next one might be
sandwich and so forth but each but the
number of the number that it goes is in
each position is going to correspond to
the number of times that word was
observed in this particular text and
that's for the count vectorizer
ravillious is changing that sentence
that string of text into a numerical
vector that's in principal
high-dimensional the number of
dimensions is going to be given by that
number and that count vectorizer
transformation
now instantiated and then what we have
to do is we have to fit it to the data
that we have which is our corpus and use
that to transform the corpus yep
ternary and it transforms that to an
array and that will be basically the
input that we have for our training
problem so the and the output that we
have is what is the corresponding the
corresponding positive or negative
reviews right so we can it's not gonna
run because we've in school but we can
we can go to the solution file if you
want it should have all the exercise a
solution one yeah and it should run and
you might need to run the whole thing
yeah you will see that the second one is
more complete in terms of we have some
model evaluation and we have some other
details but in the first one we just
wanted to get you like practice with
some of the things things that you will
be doing when you're working within a
full data set which we have Amazon Alexa
set that we provide okay it's a
directory thanks all right it's a
directory thing let me see where I am
oh yeah
oops one to me alright so I'm actually
going to come in this out and run this
I'm good
ok sure work now or in short now
this is exercise one solution no if you
wanted to do that yeah sorry yeah why
did you want to do okay okay so that we
have this is the part that some of you
are working on right now and here where
we are using the fit transform and here
we are we haven't covered this section
but it's the split probably yeah might
be because it's a very small data set
and I did some inspect in this ocean
file so you will see that most software
reviews in this specific data that are
predominantly positive so this is not
very unusual to see that you know you
will get more positive reviews than they
it really does yeah it's not very
balanced but look at the first two rows
of the matrix eggs and we see it on do
the occurrences of words after it's been
vectorized all right so that's and again
this is this is weird right it's not
it's not intuitive for us as humans
looking at this representation of the
text of a shot but the reason we need to
do that is because that is what all of
the all of that machinery in machine
learning all of those algorithms that do
saw classification problems and do
things that we need other than alive
sentiment analysis require something
like this rather than the there where's
the words and then the question of how
you encode this actually determines you
know very different some little bit
but once we call it into that basic pool
at that stage we have prepared our data
prep processed and cleaned it so we are
ready to actually create the classifier
and as one more stuff after we split it
we can actually start training matrix
into two parts at random just a set of
rows that correspond to observations
from our office called the training set
and then the test set and we need to
have that so that we can actually we use
the training set to train the model -
yeah we do have it in the next but again
so now we're importing a random forest
classifier and this court classifiers
are a few others in ltk library they are
already implemented classifiers and
models that you don't you just call and
use them you do not implement the model
yourself which you can if you want to
explore but these are some of the
well-known so another one is like now
your base classifier and and there are
some others that you can play with to
see if any of them is doing a better job
than the other in a given data set that
you might have
what it's like we use the fit method to
[Music]
to fit that to the training data so you
have to give it the inputs X underscore
train and the outputs y underscore train
and then right so that's cool and that
can take a while this is a small set and
then finally we can then use predicted
once the model has been trained this
sends a noticeable classifier object we
can use a predict method to apply and
apply that to the inputs for the test
data
and we can see how well that matches
right so we can see Y predicted those
all being one but of course the data set
is Wiser's very small and I think we
only have oh is that long are we only we
only have four in the first place yes
because we have a total 27 yeah it's
pretty small but you can do this kind of
explorations in the second exercise
because it has way more lines and data
in it oh sorry that we didn't have the
time to go to the second exercise but I
hope it's self-contained and everything
is in there just let us know reach out
if you have any questions thank you so
much for coming and I hope this was
useful and thank you
[Applause]